[Musique]
alors soyez bienvenue à l'émission
tam-tam canada en direct de montréal ça
commence comme ça de bien avec la
musique c'est une nouvelle formule
d'émission on est pro apporte pas tout à
fait habitués on a beaucoup de monde
autour de la table aux couleurs de noël
bien sûr d'abord marie jobin bonjour
bonjour stéphane et puis on a vraiment
des marteaux qui est avec nous c'était
un bon jour on a aussi le sens de la de
l'équipe anglaise de radio canada
international
bonjour bonjour et les habitués des
missions il y à marie claude simard et
léo gimeno bonjour bonjour sa somme de 2
ms les autres ce sont des collègues des
deux catégories
c'est pas mal bizarre puis à famille ils
ont il ya un accident auto ils ont il ya
quatre victimes
il ya 3
personne qui aime olivier à la télé en
argent comme on disait à l'époque où si
on est on est trois musiciens un batteur
mais nous on a cinq langues ici au
canada international on va aller vers la
vidéo numéro un pour annoncer cette
nouveauté qui est disponible depuis une
semaine environ son nouveau site web
toute nouvelle application qui vous
permet tout le monde peut regarder
également ici un studio l'application
c'est un sac ça ressemble sur notre site
web présentement pour donc aller sur
votre voulu utiliser cette application
pour mieux écouter et lire nos articles
sur radio canada international donc moi
j'ai fait l'essai avec mon gros
ordinateurs plus performants toile en pl
ça nous nous avons su goog o play vous
tapez radio canada international et le
tour est joué vous allez voir le petit
logo apparaît dans comme langue 5-5 puis
impossible d fois par exemple si vous
appliquez vous appliquez vous postez
vous piquez vous presser sur
l'application français ils veulent la
voir en espagnol où on a deux langues
en fait toutes les langues on a 3 3
c'est à dire en toute langue étrangère
on à l'espagnol puis les deux langues
officielles l'anglais français et pour
l'anglais seller france et l'espagnol
puig mais pour les français c'est
l'anglais l'espagnol je pense si
moubarak
et moi je vais déjà télécharger ça sur
mon téléphone celle là vous avez fait ça
où tout maintenant ça fait deux jours
avant donc je d'histoire ancien en fait
c'est disponible pour les deux
plateformes la plateforme c'est à dire
ap
en droit puis vous pouvez faire cliquer
sur la page si vous naviguez dans votre
téléphone sur nos pages l'hélico ni et
hambourg pouvoir faire cliquer ouvrir
ses longs votre appareil
qu'est ce que vous voulez ils éventrent
qu'est ce que ça fait ça donne un
meilleur accès aux balades au par
exemple aux autres view on a fait ça
dans meilleur accès c'est beaucoup plus
vite que aller de brothers quand on dit
d'un navigateur travaux c'est c'est
beaucoup plus vite comme ça les photos
regardez c'est comme ça que la page en
anglais s'affiche sur mon téléphone a
prédit à plusieurs sauces et pas
seulement la vitesse la vitesse est une
des choses serait la deuxième chose
c'est que on peut aimer poussée des
informations importantes
c'est à dire si vous avez l'application
puis nous on a une formation de deux
minutes on veut on peut les pousser pour
que vous la voyez un premier et vous
pouvez argumenter pour les gens qui
comme moi que je de la presbytie je vois
pas bien il faut que j'enlève mes
lunettes je pu agrandir le caractère à
l'intérieur de l'application il ya aussi
la possibilité d vous était une étoile
puis pouvoir le lire et vais pouvoir les
lire et et mais vous allez jeu pour les
voir ses pieds vous les mettez pour le
lead appris ça marche donc faire du
référencement
alors écoutez nous avons un invité
spécial c'est seulement sa troisième
fois et cette émission est la bonne on
est très contents vous à voir ici
notamment pour participer au sujet de
l'émission on va découvrir tous ensemble
quel est ce sujet dans quelques instants
pour le moment c'est vous qui est à
l'honneur s'il y avait un roi il c'est
l'émission aucune couronne ce serait
vous parce que on appelle ça le long
format c'est un nouveau produit coffre
radio canada international depuis
quelques mois maintenant et tour à tour
les différents membres de radio canada
international travaille sur des longues
arctique qui sont mises en ligne le
week-end quand les gens plus de temps
pour consommer ce genre de produits est
pas que radio canada international qui
va vers cette tendance mais c'est une
affaire mondiale
vous revenez d'un voyage très très loin
on va regarder les images que tu as
long format signé la veine seventh
disponible à partir de samedi
en fait à partir de maintenant la porte
de clichy en fait il est disponible
toute la semaine déjà moi j'étais en
regarder les images ça vous immerge dans
des fjords de norvège sont des bateaux
d'autant qu'on voit c'est le but qui
était de bateau ville de québec vidéo
numéro 2 s'il vous plaît parfait tout et
tout et la [ __ ] et tous les gens mixer
d'ailleurs dans les origines de l'otan
une des tâches du canada était de
défendre la norvège rien ces dix
exercices en norvège systématiquement
chaque année c'était les exercices les
plus grands de l'otan depuis de la fin
de la guerre froide
on avait cinquante mille soldats
d'autant de tous les pays d'autant plus
finances et suède qui sont des pays
neutres mais ils ont envoyé quand même
un contingent ou groupes militaires
communes
le canada avait envoyé vers 2000 soldats
quatre navires huit avions de chasse
deux avions chasseurs sous-marins
c'est beaucoup pour c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup c'était le plus grand des
ossements sont canadiens depuis notre
retour d'afghanistan
alors vous êtes mélangés aux militaires
en norvège vous on vous a ouvert
oui de deux façons jeté comme on part un
peu embedded intégrés intégré avec les
forces canadiennes mais il faut dire que
c'est parce que c'était un exercice qui
était tellement grand que s'étaient
répartis un peu partout dans le centre
de nowruz alors vous avez eu des unités
canadiens qui étaient comme à peu près
de 200 km dans l'autre
est-ce que ça c'était le jour de
l'ouverture officielle médiatiques ont
le temps à manifester un peu sa force
militaire vous avez vous voyez les
bateaux les navires militaires
les soldats les marins américains
néerlandais et britanniques qui un peu
montré un peu l'attaquant fib écrit avec
des avions de chasse
bombardier qui partait en haut c'était
assez impressionné mais où sont les
russes à rabat les russes c'est ce qui
reste la dérive en plus aussi c'est
quand on regarde la carte la norvège
fait le tour carrément de la suède ayant
une frontière russo norvégienne a
presque 200 km2
on gère test région veut se préparer à
quoi avec un exercice comme celui là on
se prépare à une guerre ce qui ce qui
est intéressant c'est ce que cet
exercice marque
cette fois c'est un changement radical
de deux façons que le temps s'entraîne
parce que pendant le dernier
depuis 2000 le temps s'entraîner pour
des opérations compteur insurge ans
comme en afghanistan ou irak
maintenant avec les tensions qui montent
avec la russie un crime est un crime on
a vu dernièrement le temps commence à
retourner à nancy à son ancienne mission
d'aller moix oui de de s'entraîner
contre une guerre avec une pays qui a
autant de force que le temps je pas
combien de mots vous avez écris moi je
vais lui sans au moins 15000 m'ont alors
c'est à lire ce week-end prenez le temps
en prenez le temps de six mille mots
justes ils m'ont fait tout et ça revient
à dire où finit le fameux proverbe de
jeu cesa n'est pas qu'un point si vis
pacem para bellum si tu veux la paix
prépare moi j'ai préparé pour vous une
émission aujourd'hui avec un sujet et
puis vous connaissez la tactique qu'on
n'utilise pas une tactique militaire
mais font toute façon on est prêt c'est
la vidéo 5 images et en général raymond
tu devines le sujet de mission dès la
demande et en images non il s'enquit
marqué trois images non 3 5 images vidéo
numéro trois de la pollution en partie
sur la bonne piste de façon générale ils
n'ont pas brillé vous cacher imaginez
retrait
sans rien bon c'est confirmé par l'image
numéro 4 mais l'image numéro 5 devrait
encore nuancer dans du vin de questions
aujourd'hui dans le secteur automotive
faire des mises à pied ontario mais
maryse les literies voitures électriques
les bouleversements des véhicules
électriques autonomes la voiture
électrique c'est lance déjà à peine
qu'elle frappe à la grande vitesse v
notre société on va parler de mises à
pied mais aussi de quelques occasions
d'affaires de renouveau au sein de
l'industrie des grands bouleversements à
venir et puis ce qui s'est passé il ya
la semaine dernière lundi dernier la
semaine dernière du côté de la de gm qui
a annoncé une fermeture en 2010 9,1 de
choix notamment être cesser le signe du
des choses qui vont se produire dans le
futur on va présenter la vidéo aux
internautes qui sont avec nous qui eux
n'étaient pas au canada ont peut-être
raté cette affaire là tout le monde se
met au diapason on regarde vidéo 2004 et
ensuite en rediscute en simple du son
voyage de deux le travailleur donc le cd
images qui vous montre ses cuisines
ils ont plein sur la ville d'oshawa en
ontario le consultat jihem ferait une
importante annonce demain matin
possiblement un plan de restructuration
de ses activités à l'échelle mondiale
appelant philippe qui pourrait se
traduire par d'importantes pertes
d'emplois à l'usiné d'oshawa parce que
general motors veut recentrer ses
activités vers les véhicules électriques
et véhicules je trouve pour seul à la
maison josé flament est désemparé il a
donné 16 ans à gm le tiers de sa vie
puis soudainement il apprend qu'il sera
mise à pied dans un an quand l' usine
fermera après avoir fait tout ce qu'on
nous a demandé de faire un travail sur
la langue se classent le plus difficile
sera d'en discuter avec sa fille de 10
ans à des scènes inquiète pour son papa
comme
un qashqai assurées assure une enfant de
10 ans sont strohl quand même je connais
pas mon futur je peux pas j'ai un vrai
challenge vous donne confiance
j'ai parlé à la lazio 2e hier soir j'ai
parlé au premier ministre ce matin à
violer d'accord qu'on va faire à tout ce
qu'on peut pour aider les travailleurs
est un petit peu difficile de croire que
l'auto électrique qui est l'auto
autonomes puissent être responsable de
ce que l'on voit dès maintenant alors
qu'il n'ya pas encore véritablement de
véhicules autonomes au canada c'est
encore à l'état d'expérimentation
ce sont exactement au niveau de l'auto
électrique pour bien situer la faire
vous avez une auto électrique une auto
hybride rechargeable est content bien
sûr fait partie de la révolution qui a
commencé dans le cadre de l'auto vote
parce que c'est une volt de gm
ça commence en quelle année ça dépend du
modèle moi j'ai la première génération
d'accord il faut évidemment dévoilé
mettre les cartes sur table tout dire
moi aussi j'avais que l'automobile
électrique
le sien est totalement électrique la
mienne et hybrides rubrique m de rayon
d'action 385 km sauf en hiver de 145 ans
qui l'avait soutenu urbaine vraiment
c'est vrai alors juste pour vous donner
des chiffres et si au niveau de ce qui
se passe actuellement les modèles les
plus populaires était la chevrolet volt
ça c'est de l'auto électrique purement
électriques les modèles x et s pour
personnes bien nanties de tesla est pour
les gens du rpt et joie et la chevrolet
volt était une fois de plus l'an dernier
le modèle hybride rechargeable le plus
populaire s'est faite directement les
tests là c'est vrai oui thalmann numéro
3 la 306 a fait pas longtemps cessé
d'aider des problèmes pour pour tesla
pour ses productions y avait des gens
qui voulaient acheter pied finalement ce
n'était pas le prix qu'ils avaient d'ide
et ça ne serait pas assez vite de
cuisine
absolument alors on peut voir dans la
rue déjà quelques modèles 3g déjà
consulter ce site jmm et dans la
construction de voitures et qu'ils ont
une usine en ontario
pourquoi ils ne pourraient pas fabriquer
une partie de leurs voitures électriques
en ontario mais c'est une bonne question
ce que les responsables du secteur
automobile dit c'est que on va avoir
besoin de moins de man pour fabriquer
les autres des futurs pour les autos
électriques ça moins de morceaux qui
gars alors ça veut dire moins de
vendeurs de pièces usagées ou de pièces
frauduleuses ou de pièces du court et
moins de temps pour assembler un
véhicule alors c'est la réalité c'est
que si vous avez je sais pas moi je vous
sortir un chef trente mille employés
bien dans le futur vous aurez peut-être
besoin de 25 mille employés y même
timide oui mais je veux pas être trop
pessimiste
je vais vous emmener vers notre premier
jeu là la grosse boule les éclairages et
c'est le nouveau règlement paloma vous
ne connaissez pas mais on l'appliqué
c'est quand même dur comme fer
ou plutôt de gagner des points vous vous
éviter de perdre des points d'accord il
ya 100 points à perdre durant l'émission
à travers trois jeux là pour le premier
jeu c'est vrai mais il est sûr que vous
voulez des réponses parce que l'on n'a
pas le goût de répondre on va perdre nos
points si vous répondez pas vous perdre
demain vous voilà c'est le règlement
stéphane la vidéo numéro je pense 5 va
accompagner notre propre ball oui la
première boule c'est pour vous montrer
qu'on a tiré l'information cette
première question d'un reportage nous on
affiche toujours des reportages des
entrevues qui suivent notre émission
tabler sur la première page de tam-tam
ya toujours découvrez nos archers sur le
même sujet donc vous voulez compléter la
la lecture la découverte de notre sujet
du jour vous le faites à travers les
articles en voici un
on parlait du nombre de véhicules vendus
l'an dernier 10,8 1564 voici la question
les véhicules électriques représentaient
quel pourcentage de toutes les ventes de
véhicules l'an dernier au pays à un
choix soit de réponse 2007 on n'a pas
les chefs de 2018 encore
alors est-ce que c'est à 0,4 pour cent
de tous les véhicules étaient electric
1,4 pour cent pour le choix b ou c 3,4
pour cent de toutes les ventes
il ya aussi des options qu'on aime
beaucoup aucune de ces réponses
alors on a deux aucune de ces réponses
et c'était quoi les deux premières à 0
24% et b 1 4%
moi je vais tenter le 1,4 à 24% pour
maryse vous aussi d'accord - les 3,1
quelqu'un les 3 4% très optimiste très
très optimiste rope optimisme trop
optimistes alors c'est la bonne réponse
et b qui a répondu b4 pour ça vous
conservez vos points félicitations ce
que je pensais les autres ont perdu 20
points c'est dommage voilà juste pour
vous montrer un autre reportage qui
était fait par alléchante al jasem de
notre section française de radio-canada
international ça s'appelle le taxi en
avant tout où on l'a appelé comme ça
nous vous ils vous parlent du la
compagnie taxi nouvelle compagnie taxi
qui s'appelle eu quelque chose qu'est ce
que c'est un taxiway alors il faut parce
que je joue si tout va bien
à force de regarder la lumière brille un
temps on voit puce qui est pas alors
voilà elle a même fait une entrevue et
que cet homme là qu'elle s'apprête à
nommer je vous montrer comment ça
fonctionne le site poursuit munitions
sont jamais allées qui viennent juste
nous voir sur facebook ou sur youtube
voilà vous cliquez et la l'entrevue
comme président et cofondateur de
l'entreprise hitachi est exact mais
finalement elle nous avons repris le
chemin vraiment eu couvert l'allemand
une part pour la modernisation de
l'industrie puis deuxièmement vraiment
pour l'environnement fait alors je sors
québec c'est à écouter sur notre site
et cet homme vous décrit cette nouvelle
initiative dans le domaine du tax
électrique à montréal il y en a une
autre compagnie vidéo numéro 7
si vos taxes et oui vous déjà les dents
sauter haute action normes et on les
voit pas ce qu'il soit très très bien
identifier la soirée temps avec le
bonjour
ouais
alors ça c'est ithaque ci est acceptée
vous allez voir dans quelques instants
c'est anvers c'est l'autre compagnie qui
s'appelle t aux taxis dans cette attaque
si sa série taxi
soyons clairs et le bonjour ça
s'applique dans l'ensemble peu importe
que vous soyez électrique ou non ça
c'était au avec le toit vert et la base
sans le bon jour peut-être les images
ont été prises avant l'an dernier alors
que le bonjour est devenue la marque de
commerce de la ville
un nouveau son emblème de la ville alors
j'ai une question par rapport à ces
véhicules de taxi nouveau ithaque see
you soon expliqué dans cette entrevue
qu'il n'avait pas entendu que ces
véhicules sont spéciaux ces véhicules en
cours d'homologation au canada entre 25
et 50 d'ici la fin d'année sont beaucoup
plus économique que les principaux
concurrents 30 points internes pour la
deuxième boule de la journée une a très
vite et nous appellent à ce que je
prends la pelle ou à vous de vous prenez
la peine voici la question ces véhicules
sont fabriqués importé de quel pays
avant d'être complètement équipé ici à
du mexique
lb du brésil c'est de la chine ou des de
l'allemagne quelle est l origine du
monsieur qui a accompagné je ne sais pas
s'ils s'appellent hung song et les choix
brésil non à mexique b brésil c'est
chine d allemagne
je me dois de chine chen corp évidemment
je suis pas moi je vais tenter je serais
tentée par le brésil ou l'allemagne mais
je vais aller avec l'allemagne pour deux
îles en allemagne et aussi merci le
mexique pour le mexique mexico célèbre
peintre mais j'ai dit moi c'est
d'évidence la chine réponse une station
j'ai perdu des points alors qu'ils
conservent six points mérités jours du
mois alors on fait le tour de temps pour
que vous n'oubliez pas quel est votre
score en ce moment au niveau des points
maryse où exactement parce qu'on est on
était go 1 718
pour le moment les deux champions
vraiment on vient de perdre combien
l'empreinte et avant le premier coup on
a perdu 20 on a 80 90 81 t'est voulait
venu 70 60 et ce mondial sans papiers
pendant cinq ans notre invité spécial
est avec nous il s'agit de yann simon
qui a déjà participé à cette émission
c'est au mois de septembre monsieur
simon oui effectivement c'était au début
de l'automne
est-ce que vous rappeler du contexte
parce que moi j'ai oublié comme
d'habitude et qui s'ouvre est même plus
tard et nos défauts on était en pleine
renégociation de l'alena de ce qui
allait s'appeler la hutte et dans
l'accord est fatigué mais voilà on avait
parlé justement les changements qu'ils
allaient toucher l'industrie automobile
notamment une des mesures qui favorisent
de plus hauts salaires dans les usines
et des mesures aussi qui renforce le
contenu régional notamment sans compter
des autres éléments cet accord qui ont
été négocié à la dernière minute alors
monsieur simon vous êtes au département
de management de l'université laval à
québec c'est aussi le directeur du
centre interuniversitaire de recherche
sur réseaux d'entreprise la logistique
et le transport
d'où l'intérêt de pouvoir vous parler
enfin aujourd'hui de ces bouleversements
qui nous attendent d'ici au niveau des
véhicules électriques et autonome vu
comme ça parce que moi je suis pas un
spécialiste mais j'ai l'impression que
les véhicules autonomes vont avoir un
impact encore plus grand que les
véhicules électriques au niveau du des
changements des modes de faim par quoi
on commence pour essayer de d'avertir
tout le monde sait ce qu'il ya en ce
moment trois gars de vagues qui à 10
degrés devant l'industrie automobile
vous avez mentionné effectivement la
question des véhicules électriques et la
durabilité
les véhicules autonomes ça aussi ça
devient une préoccupation majeure on y
pense tout bas et ajoutez à ça le fait
que
il ya un changement dans les deux
propriétés de vision de ce qui
représente la mobilité pour les gens
c'est à dire que il ya de plus en plus
de jeunes par exemple dans des grandes
villes car c'est surtout les urbains qui
sont concernés par cette avance là qui
décident ou bien de ne pas avoir de
permis ou bien lorsqu'ils l'ont de ne
pas acheter de véhicules et de souscrire
à des services d'autopartage donc ce que
ça veut dire c'est que les entreprises
qui fabriquent les automobiles elles
verront leur modèle de revenus changer
complètement sinon elles disparaîtront
tout simplement donc l'industrie a peur
de ces trois tendances là parce que
personne ne sait quand et comment elles
frapperont exactement mais pour foot
réunionnais cinq ans au milieu des
années 2020
on devrait être là fermement dans ce
nouveau monde a pris mais j aime bien de
poser un geste important a annoncé donc
c'est le début de la guerre si l'on voit
fleurir outillés en fonction des
nouveaux objectifs du futur
il ya d'autres compagnies qui n'ont pas
encore annoncé leurs couleurs je pense à
volkswagen par exemple qui est un petit
peu sur le côté mais qui je pense en
voit déjà des signes aux syndicats qu'il
va y avoir des mises à pied très
importante et on sait pas encore comment
composer avec ça qui est bien placé et
quand je vous demande qui est bien placé
c'est pas seulement les compagnies mais
les pays bas
évidemment les pays occidentaux
traditionnels penser à l'europe de
l'ouest bon france au premier chef et
bon l'angleterre mais pour des raisons
sont liées à des capitaux indiens et
dans des segments plus de luxe les
etats-unis eux n'auront pas le choix que
de changer la configuration de leur
industrie et le canada a dit cochet
n'aura pas le choix de le faire parce
que notre chaîne de valeur est très
intégrée avec celle des états unis
bien évidemment le japon lui aussi est
une partie prenante très important à
cause de la technologie qui ensemble et
parce que ce qui peut venue du grand
public ce qui est des goulots
d'étranglement technologique si on peut
les exprimer comme ça au japon il ya des
produits
embarquez à terre des automobiles qui
sont presque exclusivement fabriqués au
japon certains types de technologies
propriétaires qu'on garde jalousement du
côté des japonais
mais l'effervescence et le pouvoir de
marché lui il nous vient de la chine
parce que la chine s'établit où le
nombre de constructeurs foisonnent où
les occidentaux ont fait très rapidement
les alliances et a marché qui est le
premier marché maintenant de gm donc ça
vous donne un peu l'idée que le centre
de gravité de la planète automobile se
déplacent drôlement vers l'asie c'est un
jeu ciment pendant qu'ils nous parler
pendant qu'on vous pose des questions
ici au tour de table avec tout le groupe
on va présenter des images de ces
véhicules autonomes à partir de
reportages de siby si tout à fait récent
% le sont pour vous montrer à quoi
ressemble ce futur qui est programmé
quelque part qui au tournant à tabac une
question mais moi j'avais une question
parce qu'il ya eu des accidents graves
avec des véhicules autonomes y aura
peut-être des poursuites légales une
voiture autonome ça roule très bien
lorsque la route est claire il n'y a pas
de magie a pas de glace comment on
remplace l'humain qui pue dc10 et bliss
ou non ou si ça va glisser
il ya combien de voitures derrière pour
faire les bons choix sur la route ça
c'est une excellente question il les
constructeurs ne l'ont pas les adieux au
complet c'est à dire que lorsqu'on parle
autonomisation là on parle généralement
la présence de cinq stades le premier
stade étant le stade 2 le plus basique
si vous passez l'expression ou là on a
vraiment une électronique embarquée
assez rudimentaire c'est un peu votre
véhicule de luxe des fin des années 80
début des années 90 par exemple au stand
numéro 5 ou la doute et autonome
le problème réside dans le fait qu'en ce
moment on n'a pas trouvé la manière de
remplacer l'humain efficacement on parle
par exemple d'un accident ces lettres
d'une tesla d'un conducteur qui fuit à
pleine vitesse a foncé dans un semi
remorque
parce que l'ordinateur embarqué a
confondu la couleur blanche de la
remorque avec
l'osm en du ciel et donc ce genre de
détails technologiques là n'est pas du
tout anodin faut dire que dans l'absolu
les véhicules autonomes sont quand même
relativement plus sécuritaire que les
véhicules non autonomes sauf qu'il ya un
mais est ce vrai c'est qu'il faut
prévoir de lesparre pour l'intervention
humaine
là où il ya un danger en ce moment c'est
que beaucoup de gens sous contracte leur
processus de décision lorsqu'ils
conduisent à leur véhicule par exemple
pour les systèmes d'assistance à un
changement de voie ou le système de
freinage automatique
ces systèmes ils ont été conduits pour
être complémentaire avec l'action du
conducteur mais il ya les humains on est
des bêtes
lorsque vous êtes par exemple sur une
ligne droite pendant un certain temps
votre esprit décroche et vous êtes
soudainement moins alerte
c'est la même chose dans un véhicule
autonome c'est-à-dire qu'il faut réduire
votre charge cognitive
mais tout en vous donnant les conditions
où vous allez être en mesure de réagir
très vite si un accident et ses lacunes
réticences répond et ajoutez à ça la
question et cycle qui est en filigrane
dans la question vous venez poser c'est
à dire que bon signe on sait qu'on va
avoir un accident
comment fait-on le calcul de dédommager
de où le véhicule devrait évacuer et
empirique et qu on va éviter donc
est-ce qu'on va choisir un couple avec
un enfant ou un vieillard qui traverse
les rues et tout à fait est actuellement
les algorithmes peuvent faire de tels
choix si on leur dit comment le problème
c'est que dans seulement où il ya de
plus en plus d'électronique embarquée
d'intelligence artificielle ajouté dans
ses systèmes de décision là et bien on
sait pas nécessairement comment les
algorithmes apprendront ce genre et qui
a fait jeudi un cargo rythme est ce
qu'on choisirait un homme ou une femme
une personne était plus âgé one entre
une personne qui n'est pas une personne
qui vient d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
c'est des questions très complexes posés
oui c'est des questions tout à fait
légitimes parce que on a découvert par
exemple qui avait dévié systématique
dans des logiciels de reconnaissance
faciale
pourquoi parce que les ensembles dans
evènement ces logiciels là étaient les
ensembles basé sur les ingénieurs qui
ont lancé les projets qui dans les
années 70 80 et des ingénieurs de la
donc le système de reconnaissance
faciale sont excellents chez les blancs
mais moins bon chez les minorités
visibles
donc vous avez ce genre de calcul de qui
entrent en ligne de compte aussi par
exemple lorsqu'on parle d'intelligence
artificielle dans les véhicules
embarqués il ya des caméras maintenant
et des ordinateurs qui peuvent analyser
le terrain en temps réel pour savoir
s'il faut freiner il faut tourner ou pas
selon ton s'est aperçu c'est que par
exemple certains logiciels le
reconnaissait très mal des
caractéristiques la peinture versus un
trou d'eau mille poules
écoutez sans raison magnifique question
maryse alors jeunes aux questions ou
plein légal disons les des bureaux
d'avocats vont seulement en débatte de
là dessus là dessus pendant des années
si j'ai un accident et tout est autonome
sur mon véhicule est ce que je suis
quand même pas responsable au fin fond
des choses si c'est mon auto c'est le
céleri ou l'ordinateur de bord qui est
responsable
à ce moment puisque il n'y a pas de
d'autonomie totale ou votre votre
jugement qu'on du temps les plus
sollicités vous êtes encore le
conducteur de votre véhicule
c'est à dire que votre système vous aide
à freiner vous aident à pas diverger de
votre voix vous êtes à votre trajectoire
gps par exemple
mais pour les décisions immédiates
d'urgence vous êtes encore un contrôle
et vous pouvez saisir le contrôler à
tout moment donc dans ce cas ci de vous
fier un peu trop à l'électronique
embarquée disons que ce serait dangereux
pour vous et votre assureur ne voulait
chargera pas de votre responsabilité
qu'en dit quant à lui dans un monde où
on serait complètement autonome plus
dans un monde où yann transition avec
une partie de la flotte qui est conduite
par des humains et l'autre partie par
des véhicules autonomes
la question reste posée drôlement et il
ya des assureurs qui ont commencé à y
penser notamment au royaume uni pour
savoir justement comment elle plus de
temps la faute au dernier de la grue
ou alors au conducteur ou designers du
véhicule qui lui aurait peut-être pas
tenu compte de cet acteur suffisamment
dans sont des ânes de véhicules et là
vous vous imaginez que vous allez
changer de les obligations des
constructeurs et des designers
est ce que ça va faire ça va se
répercuter dans le prix des véhicules et
dans le modèle d'affaires la manière
dont sera vendu parce qu'on saura que si
vous faites un accident et que le
constructeur est responsable de milliers
voire des centaines d'amis d'unités ben
là il va provisionner pour ce type
d'événement là et la provision reviendra
bien évidemment de la poche du
consommateur et autres grands
changements également que je vois venir
c'est avec ces véhicules là qui sont
soient électriques soient hybrides ou
soit partiellement ou totalement
autonome il ya un changement majeur de
toute l'économie notamment
nord-américaine je parle de ces petits
garages de coin de rue qui disparaîtront
la mécanique automobile elle même risque
de changer de façon draconienne
oui et on l'a déjà expérimenté avec
l'avènement des systèmes embarqués dans
une attente de votre l'hécatombe chez
les mécaniciennes de quartier ont
commencé à produire il ya plusieurs
années quand les constructeurs ont mis
de plus en plus d'électronique à bord ou
de systèmes de diagnostic et cette
tendance là ne fera que s'accélérer
on peut imaginer vous voyez par grand
vent vous concessionnaires automobiles
préféré avec des véhicules très récent
souvent ça s'apparente plus au dépannage
informatique cada mécanique pure et
simple est donc le métier même de
techniciens a le droit bill va changer
de façon très importante et la nature
des investissements pour s'équiper pour
avoir une entreprise qui fait ce genre
de service pour les consommateurs va
aussi augmenter de façon substantielle
le sonim donc là encore une fois
malheureusement comme consommateur la
chaîne de causalité c'est percutant
gauche mais il faut voir que le paysage
va changer de façon très important
professionnels et l'économie en général
parce que plus d auto électrique moyenne
d'essence puis les sens ça bouge notre
pays par exemple les fabricants de
batteries le canada dans ce genre de
technologie a au québec en ontario
notamment mais aussi encore britannique
et au nord de l'alberta passé à être
notamment et calgary
vous avez des entreprises sont très très
bonnes dans ce domaine là et donc on est
quand même relativement bien placé pour
reprendre cette vague là mais la
transition ne se fera pas sans coûts
qu'est-ce qu'on gagnera du côté des
piles ben là il faudra se donner des
processus pour reconditionner étendre la
johnny depuis de ces pays là parce que
une pile qu'il y ait enfin durée de vie
c'est une pile qu'un coût
environnemental très important et voilà
pour le pétrole est bien là vous misez
juste il faudra repasser
on fera avec les travailleurs cette
industrie là et comment est ce qu'on
gérera le transfert de richesse sopel
rod secteur de sous secteurs de
l'énergie vers un autre raymond l'autre
jour il ya un coin deux chemins devant
me parliez d'un
un article disant que les autos
électriques avant une empreinte
environnementale insoupçonnées que
c'était en fait terrible comparé aux
véhicules en assurant faire ça pas trop
à ça j'ai pensé qu'elle se 50000 km mais
moi je peux sentir un peu comme c'était
d'un contre contre ouais comme c'est
comme les fabricants de sucre qui disent
non ça va très bien c'est très bon le
sud pour la santé ça donne de l'énergie
ou six ou sept professeurs de physique
qui disait il faut mettre des panneaux
salaire passe avons vidé le soleil ouais
on sent un peu la constitution là quand
et sur une marge qui a dit bart y avoir
des intérêts économiques qui vont
s'opposer à tout ça il y en a sûrement
et ça vous savez c'est pas inconnu ça
arrive en plein d'autres secteurs
économiques
sauf que lorsqu'il s'agit de décider le
type de technologie qu'on souhaite
adopter ou le type de véhicule qu'on
souhaite adopter pour réduire son
empreinte faut savoir que plusieurs
études très sérieuses et pas du tout
limmat aux sceptiques montre qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de nuances à faire
c'est à dire que quand on a montré que
si vous êtes au centre des états unis
vous avez probablement des sources
d'électricité qui viennent charbon et
l'on peut acheter logique d'avoir à
riscle électrique à compte de
l'augmentation consommation charbon pour
lacoste où il ya à la fois nucléaire
hydroélectricité là les chercheurs ont
fait une carte avec une jolie zone verte
parce que là le gain environnemental il
est évident au sens où le il n'y a pas
de substitution des missions pour
d'autres émissions l'alien games est
mais il n'ya pas malheureusement de
règle 10 pouces ou vous pouvez vous
acheter une électrique peu importe où
vous habitez et penser que vous faites
votre devoir pour l'environnement
malheureusement ça dépend beaucoup de
votre sur des christ et de canadiens que
respecter ou pas de votre véhicule et de
plein d'autres facteurs y est votre
utilisation
donc oui il ya un gain environnemental à
l'électrification des véhicules
il ya aussi un gain à vouloir rouler
plus
or mais encore une fois il faut utiliser
son jugement et regarder l'ensemble de
la chaîne parce que une choses
insoupçonnées c'est que plus de
véhicules électriques sur la route ça
voudra dire peut-être moins d'émissions
due au pétrole mais çà voudra peut-être
pas dire l'élimination des
embouteillages a pris donc ce danger là
il ya la volonté ne s'effacera pas
nécessairement un sous texte de ce que
vous dites moi j'entends des choses un
vive l'hydroélectricité et de vivre le
transport en commun et où le vélo mais
que ça a quel prix combien on paie
l'électricité et combien on paie pour se
procurer le véhicule important se
produire sa propre électricité dernière
moi je trouve qu a chaque fois quand on
aborde le sujet du véhicule électrique
comme un éléphant dans la pièce c'est
toujours en réalité on peut pas se
permettre de l'acheter la plupart des
gens ne peuvent pas se payer moi je peux
pas me le payer
comme s'y attend pas on expliqué à
20minutes quelque chose des travailleurs
qui camperont voilà qu'on fait et qui
sont pas deux qui sont seuls non le vent
en france en moins là on ya des
manifestations à cause de l'augmentation
du prix de l'essence ouais mais la
plupart de ces gens là qui manifestent
n'ont pas nécessairement les moyens de
s'acheter un dégagement alors ça va être
accessible qu'un pour tout le monde
c'est ouvrir électrique justement moi je
fais partie des appels les plus jeunes
devant de 10 millions on voit de plus en
plus dans cette génération là la
mobilité comme un service et le
transport individuel comme un cocktail
de transport donc une combinaison de
différents moyens de transport qui dit
vélo vélopartage transports en commun
chera dans ce paradis
de mobilité et les constructeurs
certains comme volvo par exemple
commencent à y réfléchir sérieusement
on peut imaginer que l'autopartage
s'étendra justement vers les véhicules
électriques où on donnera des forfaits
aux consommateurs qui lui permettront
avec un coût mensuel prédéterminé
d'avoir accès à des blocs d'utilisation
de véhicules donc vous aurez davantage
de payer beaucoup moins cher que si vous
aviez votre véhicule vous même combiné
au fait que cet actif là bas elle sera
partagée donc n'aura pas besoin de
produire cinq véhicules pour 5 personnes
puisque en temps partagé on aura
peut-être besoin d'un véhicule ennemi
pour ces cinq personnes là mais c'est
que tout le monde veille le même bloc
pour partir au travail le matin et c'est
là qu'il faut nous intéressant ou un
très bon système de prix pour réguler
les ardeurs s2 qui souhaite un bon
écoutez moi faux j'ai changé mon en deux
merci beaucoup d'avoir exercé en cours
ouais et je sais que c'est ça la bonne
journée simon professeur au département
de management université de laval à
québec
j'ai quelqu'un il faut prendre le temps
pour essayer de le convaincre de venir
pas parce qu'il veut pas mais parce que
il a 36 choses à faire notamment les
vieux véhicules ford avec la crainte je
m'en souviens
non mais pour ce qui est du calcul moi
j'ai dû faire un calcul en disant est ce
que j'achète encore un véhicule usagé
6000 dollars à raison de 500 dollars par
mois en essence il si je calcule de 500
leur accent le coach je voyage beaucoup
de 500 dollars par mois
j'habite loin j'ai fait le compte ça
fait 6000 $ par année alors si j'ajoute
ceci 1000 $ un véhicule électrique qui
est doit en principe être resté en vie
plus longtemps qu'un véhicule à
combustion avec plein de morceaux qui
m'ont cassé
ben j'ai fait le calcul en disant ce jeu
arrive au même niveau mais au moins je
vais avoir le
le plaisir l'esprit tranquille l'esprit
tranquille de que ça va casser moins
souvent je suis sain ce jeu je me suis
dit ça parce qu'à avec leurs abeilles
comment j'habite dans une promotion un
rabais de 14 ans elle partage des
déplacements en ville très copiés vous
le voyez les gens au centre-ville de qui
vont ils ou les petites autos à la demi
heure là qu'ils les stations partout
mais ma question c'est toujours la même
chose que moi après avec toutes les
piles les bacs
il ya une chose qui doit rentrer en
ligne de compte aussi dans d'abord deux
choses par le québec
6000 $ pour les véhicules neufs ou 4000
pour l'usager c'est selon dans le cas de
la mienne n'y en avait pas de ct usagers
et hybrides rechargeables et non pas
totalement électrique voilà attendent
une aide financière de grands airs voilà
c'est ça d'une part mais d'autre part un
les les batteries cette partie là qui
pose problème mais dans le cas qui nous
occupe
on parle de 30000 charge avant que la
batterie soit 18 et 30 mille charge à
une charge par année comptez le nombre
d'années que j'ai commencé une charge
par année ça pue charge par jour au
pardon en charge par jour auxquels je
m'en donner à voir se défaire des métaux
et dans certains cas des métaux qui sont
problématiques
ils ont en train de les panneaux
solaires il ya beaucoup de répercussions
il ya des des lignes de recherche qui
disent qu'ils sont en train de faire une
pollution du ciem degré parce qu'ils se
sont fait avec des matériaux qui se
recyclent pas ils ont utile maintenant
il pose pas de problème mais mais dans
30 40
c'est un fait que la question se pose
mais la question se pose aussi est-ce
qu'on fait quelque chose comme ça ou est
ce qu'on continue avec le pétrole
non non j'ai confirmé les l'histoire s'y
plaît pensez à
vraiment future puis essayer d
exactement de la même façon je sais pas
pour vous lancer mais juste pour dire
que l'imaginaire et la recherche de
l'être humain est quelque chose qui est
assez intéressant d'avoir fallait régler
le problème des pluies acides
ça a été fait mais moi et hier je voyais
une vidéo sur youtube qui parlait de
recyclage habituellement ici au canada
on recycle en recycleur un cycle mais
l'histoire s'est on a un volume des
matériaux pour recycler qu'on peut pas
recycler alors la partie officielle la
vidéo il dit c'est bella pour le
troisième jeu je rappelle il ya notre
collègue la vanne qui a dû quitter pour
les stages égales entre tout le monde
l'avait quittée avant il perdait 7 500
les périodes voilà il a perdu
automatiquement rentrée 50 points du 3e
et y entrent voilà je sais pas à quel
niveau ils étaient 70 ou 80 il est à 50
10 1 15 1 % quand même sûrement pas
qu'il ait quitté premier et dernier jeux
pour 50 points à perdre
mais si la question est très charmant
c'est raymonde et berthod qui a écrit
là-dessus un article à lui à la réponse
est peut-être qu'il s'en souvient plus
ça l'a fait ça je pense il ya un an
et puis ce qui est amusant c'est que
c'est pour trouver ça sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine donc vous
voulez aller plus loin dans la
conversation dans les lectures
voici la question quel pourcentage des
canadiens font confiance aux véhicules
autonomes
[Musique]
mme bardot canadien fait pourquoi
ferions confiance à être comme ça c'est
une sous question agrément est ce qu est
ce que vous vous en souvenez podji moi
je dirais 13 pour sa 13 % ouais pas de
choix de réponses 1 13% à vous désirez
le plus proche de la bonne réponse est
le grand gagnant c'est avait un choix de
réponses niveau 13 pour sa fantastique
ensuite et 8 points 5 8 % seulement les
canadiens font confiance aux véhicules
autonomes et la confiance règne pas ici
à peine 5 5% vous avez écrit l'article
vous êtes 5 pour que glee l'article je
mens cheveux assez drôle passé le même
chiffre alors je vais aller avec toi
vraiment bien on va bien faire ou non
ouais alors qu'ils se trouvent le plus
proche de temps allez voir la bonne
réponse numéro 26 38 salué ces feux
ouais c'est ça alors est ce qui se
trouve le proche de la réponse de 46% un
bon dieu félicitations vous conservez
vos 50
je vais écrire un bouquin 26% dans les
provinces de l'ouest canadien
un petit peu moins forts au québec et
non plus par rapport à ça c'est fait
des données de l'an dernier il à l'auto
autonome a beaucoup évolué depuis ce
temps il ya eu deux ou trois accidents
plus de véhicules auto n'a pas beaucoup
sur la route est là pour bosser palace
et répond non non j'espère vous fait pas
confiance à vos systèmes être cités
quand vous conduisez parce que
fall angélique la tesla d'être là sains
fois qu'on aime voyager en restant avec
une amie montréal constants avec une
tesla puis la part du voyage s'est mis
autonome dix ans parce que les déceler
un système sécurité qui vous dit je suis
cadre lumineux drôles
il faut prendre les voleurs et volant
pour dire je suis je suis là et ça
s'entend pas il comme il les fait plus
rapidement avant dix ans d'une minute et
après une minute puis après 35 ans fine
sinon il se met à côté
il s'arrête parce qu'ils étaient
endormis appelle ma mère qui disait mon
père de ne pas s'endormir au volant qu
il réveillait c'est la pensée de demain
qui pourrait coûter
merci beaucoup d'être venu à l'émission
aujourd'hui magnifique petit cadeau au
prix de noël un nom mais vous avez des
amis quand des tesla moi je trouve ça
impressionne impressionne
[Rires]
[Musique]